hello again
uber nerd fans I heard you blew up the
Twittersphere about my sweet new feature
film the Lego Batman movie you know it's
kind of like the original lego movie
only vastly superior because it revolves
entirely around me so anyway when you're
as super as me you don't get just one
trailer you get two trailers in one week
check this out
hey mom hey Dad
I saved the city again today
I think you would have been really proud
Hey Oh Alfred I am so sorry I have
incredible reflexes I should have known
better than to sneak up on him like that
were you looking at the old family
pictures again no I wasn't sir
I've seen you go through similar phases
in 2016 in 2012 and 2008 in 2005 in 1997
in 1995 in 1992 with 1989 and that weird
one in 1966 I have aged phenomenally do
you want to talk about how you're
feeling
what no I don't want to do that sir
no sir no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no gosh I
hope we were recording that we're not
Alfred what did I say a B are always be
recording
I'll be bad 2008 a bad man I saved this
city again
Leary's off the chain anyway I should
probably have some grub Alfred left your
Lobster Thermidor in the